how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have some pretty big
and exciting news not that we haven't
recently because the whole mcu right now
is pretty exciting but
today we have a report that is stating
that ghost
writer is going to be coming to the
marvel cinematic universe and he's going
to be entering the marvel cinematic
universe
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and this has
huge implications for the mcu including
the formation of
the midnight suns a group that i know a
lot of people have been waiting for
to enter the mcu and we'll dive into it
but first
please give me a minute to thank noom
for sponsoring this video you too noom
for sponsoring today's video now i've
actually used new before they sponsored
this video
on my fitness journey on trying to
become bigger than the rock himself
i've run into a few snacks and that's
primarily food
and losing weight but noob has actually
been helping me lose weight
in fact in the first week i lost a few
pounds and that's because
nume isn't just about what you eat but
it's also about the psychology of
how you eat and that's why newm is a
huge disrupter in the healthcare
industry right now because it uses
cbt or cognitive behavioral therapy and
psychology for
preventative measures preventative
measures meaning you want to lose weight
but you keep splurging for ice cream at
2 am
noom can help prevent that newm works to
change your psychology of how you eat
and
educate you on healthy eating habits it
also offers a food and exercise
tracker a personal goal specialist and
group chat support
and if you want to pay a little extra
they offer meal plans and
exercise plans so take your free 30
second quiz
using the link that you see here and in
the description down below
and be sure to follow noom on social
media so today's report about
ghostwriter entering the mcu
is coming from that hashtag show.com in
an exclusive report
in this report they state that they can
exclusively confirm
that ghostwriter is coming to the mcu
when the rights to the character
reverted
marvel had to decide what to do with the
character so they go on to ask the
question
how does johnny blaze fit into the mcu
in which they state
i've seen concept art from doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
that shows
ghost writer from what i've seen and
heard it'll be a cameo at best but
considering multiverse of madness is
exploring the multiverse and will have
horror elements
a cameo will fit in with the movie while
not distracting too much from the rest
of the film
now they end the report by stating that
marvel is not going to bring back
gabriel luna for the role of ghost rider
which can be
pretty disappointing to some fans but
they also end it by stating that
look out for this weekend because
they're going to drop even bigger news
involving ghostwriter
so we'll get more information over the
weekend hopefully
but let's talk about what this means and
talk about who could play ghost writer
in the marvel cinematic universe and
what ghost
rider being in the mcu actually means
for the future
because i believe that ghost rider and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is actually the start of
something pretty great first of all we
do know that doctor strange in the
multiverse of
madness is supposed to be some type of
marvel
horror film now it's obviously not going
to be too over the top
don't expect it to be rated r because
i'm pretty sure it's going to be pg-13
after all that's why marvel parted ways
with the original director scott
derrickson because he really really
wanted it to be
horror but kevin feige the president of
marvel studios stepped in and said
that's
not what marvel really is we can do
horror aspects in the film but it's not
going to be a full out horror film
but with the horror aspects johnny
blaise ghost rider
would be perfect and i don't want to
start with the rumors already but we all
know how johnny blaise gets his powers
right in order to save the life of his
father he agrees to give his soul
to satan who is later on revealed to be
an archdemon the one and only
mephisto like i said we won't dive into
it but loki is mephisto
confirmed end of story goodbye now
multiverse of madness is obviously going
to explore the multiverse so
this ghost rider could actually be from
a different universe
and the report did state that it is
going to be a cameo but ghost rider is a
massive character marvel isn't just
going to bring him into one film to have
him cameo for a few seconds or something
like that and then
never show him again and a part of the
report does mention that even though
ghost rider is going to appear in this
film and could appear in other films he
could go on to get his own film as well
so clearly marvel has plans for
ghostwriter which means he's most likely
sticking around
in rmcu now the story for him probably
isn't going to be that big
it's just a cameo but perhaps we'll get
a tiny bit of an explanation or maybe he
simply used for the horror aspect of the
film
at this point we don't know however
kevin feige did mention that he has been
meeting with keanu reeves for each
marvel movie they have coming out
each marvel project that they have they
talk to keanu reeves and see if there's
a part for him
obviously they haven't come up with
something yet at least that we know of
but there were rumors before of him
possibly playing ghost rider and i think
keanu would be
a perfect fit i know a lot of people
really want him to play wolverine
but he's a little bit too old to play
wolverine however
the dude is basically ghost rider in
real life he's a super
cool guy who rides motorcycles all the
time i mean he actually founded and owns
ark motorcycles if you're looking for a
bad a guy that rides a motorcycle and
has a skull
on fire keanu reeves could be the
perfect fit for this character
but that's my personal opinion who do
you think would play a very good
ghost writer tell me your thoughts in
the comments down below now one of the
biggest things for me
about ghost rider entering the mcu is
the formation of the midnight suns
it looks like marvel is sort of planning
their own little monster verse inside of
the mcu and no i'm not talking about
like godzilla vs kong i'm talking like
actual monsters and vampires the kind
that blade hunts down
and kills marvel has announced a blade
project coming in
probably in marvel's phase 5. while at
the same time we have
moon knight coming and then we have
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which is going to be introducing
some demons into the mcu
and it looks like ghost rider and right
there we already have
four members of the midnight suns we
have doctor strange
blade ghost rider and moon knight and if
they introduce elsa bloodstone and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness which they are rumored to do
she can be a part of the midnight suns
as well and the introduction of this
group
could be very necessary because of the
darkhold the book that was introduced in
one division the midnight suns have a
pretty big history with the darkhold and
its pages
and guess what's going to be in doctor
strange in the multiverse of
madness the darkhold at the end of one
division
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
finale yet wanda has the darkhold and
she's learning from it and it looks like
she's become pretty powerful
and we know that she's going to be a
main character in multiverse of madness
which means the darkhold is going to be
in the film and could play a prominent
part
in fact it could be responsible for
unleashing some unspeakable
evil that is mentioned to be in the film
and especially if it gets into mordo's
hands who is confirmed to be returning
it's going to be doing some damage in
fact right now we're kind of
unsure of how the multiverse really got
thrown into madness it appears that the
multiverse is going to be kind of
broken before we actually get into
doctor strange 2 because
of spider-man no way home we're going to
see the multiverse in that movie so
clearly the effects aren't coming
directly
from the events in doctor strange the
blip or the snap
could have been what caused the
multiverse to kind of start to tear
that combined with some pretty powerful
magic that can alter reality
could definitely send the universe
spiraling into madness and it's probably
not
all going to be fixed in doctor strange
maybe a
huge world shattering threat could be
fixed in the film but there are probably
going to be other threats that are still
out there in the universe
which are going to have to be taken care
of enter the midnight suns the team that
comes in and does the dirty work taking
out demons taking out vampires monsters
hopefully we have keanu reeves on a
motorcycle with his skull
on fire but regardless i am definitely
excited for the introduction of ghost
rider
and the start of the midnight suns we're
getting a lot closer with blade
and moon knight and then we're going to
be getting ghost rider and multiverse of
madness so be sure to let me know what
you think about this
in the comments down below and let me
know who you think would play a good
ghost rider don't forget to subscribe to
stay up to date on all of the latest
mcu news and so you can enter my
stormbreaker giveaway details in the
description down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof